well ladies and gentlemen he did it last
night a wet and glistening Donald Trump
announced his 2024 presidential run to a
crowd of sort of bored people quite
frankly that's one of the story lines
from Mar-A-Lago which we'll get to a
little bit later but a very different
energy last night than in times past
Trump himself even seemed kind of bored
with the speech he was reading off of
his teleprompter the crowd only engaged
at a few moments and remember that many
people around Trump were telling him as
recently as Monday you should not do
this you should not do this after the
results of the 2022 midterms you should
not do this after the realization that
this isn't even really over 2022
elections until December 6 with the
runoff in Georgia and Donald Trump
deciding to do it now many of you will
remember our friend Michael Cohen
Trump's former lawyer swore up and down
to me Trump's not gonna run many others
even in my audience were emailing me as
recently as yesterday morning saying
Trump's not going to run he is running
and we are now going to have another
potentially two years of insanity in the
United States now before we get to the
clips another aspect to this that I
believe especially with the energy
behind Ron DeSantis may be very
different than in 2016 and in 2020 is
that you were going to see the people
behind Donald Trump especially those who
get behind him this early on average be
even more extreme because there are now
other options including Ron DeSantis who
hasn't declared that he's running for
anything and is already leading Trump in
most polls taken after the November 8th
midterms all of which we will get to CNN
and Fox News initially covered Trump's
speech live
uh they eventually cut away we're going
to get to that as well MSNBC ignored it
completely I tried to cover it we had
technical issues which I will address a
little bit later I got some really nasty
emails about it but I will get to that
but let's start off with already I mean
just even the way Donald Trump was
welcomed into the room was absurd
Gentlemen please welcome the next
president and famous lady of the United
States of America
Donald J Trump accompanied by Mrs
Melania Trump
Adam
American okay so just completely
horrifying from the get-go the most high
energy moment from the entire thing was
the moment that Donald Trump actually
announced
in order to make America great and
glorious again I am tonight announcing
my candidacy for president of the United
States
okay so the crowd certainly engaged
there but at almost no other time Donald
Trump was expected to go at the most
half an hour he went nearly a full hour
and got into some of the same old tired
stuff including this completely Bonkers
dictatorial idea of executing every drug
dealer like they do in China responsible
for death Carnage and crime all over our
country every drug dealer during his or
her life on average will kill 500 people
with the drugs they sell not to mention
the destruction of families
but we're going to be asking everyone
who sells drugs gets caught selling
drugs to receive the death penalty for
their heinous acts even that language is
so funny we're going to ask the drug
dealers to receive the death penalty uh
Mr drug dealer sir we would like you to
receive the death penalty please because
it's the only way
we don't need any more Blue Ribbon
committees we don't need I don't like to
say this and I don't even know of the
American public is ready for it and a
lot of my people say please don't say
that sir that's not nice they kill 500
people each on average
and if you don't do this in China when I
was with President XI I said president
do you have a drug problem no no no no
we don't he looked up that's Trump's uh
impersonation of she no no no no no so
listen this is a this is a wacky idea
and again not mincing words this is an
authoritarian extremist he would like
the United States to be even more
authoritarian but he's also a liar and a
hypocrite because Donald Trump pardoned
many drug dealers at the end of his
presidency so death penalty for drug
dealers also Trump pardoning drug
dealers at another moment during the
speech clearly gearing up for what is
going to be a contentious battle with
other Republicans it's abundantly clear
that's going to be the case during this
new presidential run Donald Trump
actually sort of going after the
Republican party but laying out a very
Bleak situation much criticism is being
placed on the fact that the Republican
Party should have done better and
frankly much of this blame is correct
but the citizens of our country have not
yet realized the full extent and gravity
of the pain our nation is going through
and the total effect of the suffering is
just starting to take hold you're going
to suffer much much more ladies and
gentlemen but you can also vote for me
and I'll fix everything even though I
fixed nothing last time and this is part
of why I think this time it may not go
so well for Trump but we'll get to that
don't quite feel it yet but they will
very soon
I have no doubt that by 2024 it will
sadly be much worse and they will see
much more clearly what happened and what
is happening to our country Yeah by by
the time you get the opportunity to vote
for me Trump says things are really
going to be bad another kind of weird
interlude and a strange thing to include
in a presidential announcement Trump's
saying again that we're going to go to
Mars at least he pronounced it correctly
this time remember that Viral moment
previously where Trump said we are going
to put a man on Nars he at least got it
right this time human knowledge and
extend the horizons of human achievement
and we will plant our beautiful American
flag very soon on the surface of Mars
which I got started the crowd is sort of
like yeah I guess so Trump said he got
that started which is of course not true
a very weird thing Trump also choosing
to float a new conspiracy theory during
this announcement that maybe China is
the one that stole the 2020 elections
from him remember he's tried everything
else it was the Democrats it was
Communist communist communalists
Communists socialists marxists all of
whom don't really exist in the United
States uh it was you know Hunter Biden's
laptop but whatever now it's and this is
very irresponsible now it might have
been China many people think that
because of this China played a very
active role
in the 2020 election just saying just
say
sure that didn't happen
all right you know like two people
clapping and what is becoming very clear
about this new run which of course it
will be another grift run for Trump to
raise money is the strategy will be lie
about all the things he he supposedly
did as president claim everything was
amazing when he was president
and then claim that again we need him to
prevent things from being terrible which
they will be under Joe Biden I guess at
another moment I I know guys it's you
you look at the calendar and you say
is is my calendar right is it November
of 2022 is it almost 2023 and Trump is
still talking about Hillary Clinton's
emails which he by the way pronounces
Clinton which is a whole other story yes
you would be right he's still talking
about that including
links right here
at Bush's Place why didn't you rate
Clinton
thousand emails why didn't you rate
Clinton's place what and you do
Obama who took a lot of things with him
yeah so I didn't know I know Trump
claims to be religious and we know that
he's not maybe this is the Festivus
airing of grievances that Donald Trump
was doing and he did indeed straight up
just say I'm a victim I'm a very big
victim thank you
and I'm a victim I will tell you I'm a
victim think of it uh thank you
surprising to some but not to others
Donald Trump did include portions of the
transphobic sections of his recent rally
speeches in his big announcement
yesterday pay attention to some
something is notable about this part we
were doing we were starting to really
get it right we will not let men as an
example participate in women's sports is
that okay no way no men no men
now the crowd is engaged
my people tell me sure that's
Politically Incorrect to say I said
that's okay I'll say it anyway if you
don't mind
so much like with CPAC recently
the transphobia and homophobia were the
most interesting moments of CPAC
speeches to that crowd
other than when Trump said I'm running
for president this was in our speech the
crowd was mostly dead dead they tried to
leave they weren't allowed we'll get to
that
um the most interesting moments of the
speech to the crowd were when Trump said
I'm running and when Trump said no men
in women's sports so that tells us quite
a bit one other thing Donald Trump
blamed the green New Deal for all sorts
of things there is no green New Deal the
green New Deal isn't law it's just a
proposal really bad
the Socialist disaster known as the
Green New Deal which is destroying our
country and the many crippling
regulations that it has spawned
will be immediately terminated so that
our country can again breathe and grow
and Thrive like it should
yeah the crowd maybe with tepid Applause
because there is no green New Deal to
end the green New Deal is a proposal
but the green new deal is not the law so
the crowd clearly confused and then
here's the end of Donald Trump's speech
the crowd just barely into it Trump
doing you know a version of the same way
he's ended his recent rally speeches
we will make America strong again
we will make America proud again
we will make America safe again
we will make America glorious again
that's a little extra addition
and we will make America great again
thank you very much God bless you all
thank you yeah
so listen
um a very different speech than at any
prior time this is going to be a very
different sort of candidacy for Donald
Trump there are options there are strong
options there are many Republicans who
are already sick of this guy
and and and
there is a completely different dynamic
in the United States with what the
Republican Party electorate looks like
so this is only the beginning we are
going to be with you for the entire
thing 2024 clearly Starts Now earlier
than ever the best thing you can do make
sure you're subscribed to our podcast
make sure you're subscribed to the
YouTube channel and be with us for the
coverage and we will see where the
country ends up there are more than
three million viewers of ours who watch
the clips but aren't subscribed on
YouTube make sure you hit that subscribe
button it's a very easy thing to do well
I told you that a lot of people looked
and sounded bored during Donald Trump's
big 2024 announcement it turns out that
it wasn't just my perception people were
trying to leave the room at Mar-A-Lago
last night and Mar-A-Lago staff blocked
people from leaving the room understand
that the Trump announcement was so
boring people were trying to get out and
they were forced to stay in the room
here is ABC's Jonathan Carl
folks this this is beyond parody it is
stunning that this is the world we now
live in listen to this incredibly low
energy I actually saw people trying to
leave
um and people leaving early even by the
way Trump is speaking right now or he
was not he's still speaking now uh and
and then they I think perhaps a little
concerned that the hallway the hall
would empty out too much they actually
started preventing people from leaving
so now they're no longer allowing
what an electric atmosphere at
Mar-A-Lago where it's quiet enough for a
reporter to do a stand-up while the
speech is still going on I mean think of
that that that in and of itself is
amazing and increasingly of course the
question is has Trump fizzled out the
polling is not looking good DeSantis is
leading Trump in just about every poll
and Trump's not even I'm sorry DeSantis
hasn't even announced that he's running
for anything yet so the question of
whether Trump fizzled out is one
question
the speech really was very low energy
and at one point the camera panned to
Trump's family and they were all just
kind of standing there awkwardly it
wasn't even really clear they were that
into it and there were some reports that
not everybody in Trump's family wanted
him to do this Ivanka Trump as far as
was reported wasn't even at the speech
and we actually have video here
um I'll play this you can see a crowd
Milling from screen right to screen left
and they're just quite literally blocked
there's a bunch of staffers in the lower
left
preventing anybody from getting out they
the the entire thing was going to empty
out and people were blocked security or
whatever these people are not letting
them leave forget about freedom of
speech they don't even have freedom of
movement at Mar-A-Lago uh so that was
quite quite remarkable here's another
moment of just how bored people were
that this was while Trump was speaking
and you see many empty seats and just
absolutely no energy here they've
devalued their currency whether it was
the pound or whether it was the one or
the Yen yeah and I used to fight
like cats and dogs with the leaders of
other countries like a dog
um video at one point also caught Roger
Stone this is pretty funny Stone was
there and I can't think of anyone
looking more bored about all of this
than Roger Stone he looks like he's
wondering where the exits are or maybe
the bar
and they let it go back up instead of
putting them
Administration has done very very openly
and bravely my god well it really was
like um like Hotel California you can
check out anytime you want but you can
never leave and much of the crowd
mentally checked out but quite literally
not allowed to leave just one more clip
here just to give you the flavor of what
was going on one guy doing YMCA okay
Chuck if you're watching look at the
middle of the room
foreign
he notices no one else is doing it and
then he stops so lower energy hard to
imagine
Trump didn't seem that into it his
family certainly didn't seem that into
it the crowd didn't seem very much into
it and one of the most interesting
aspects of this was even Fox News didn't
seem that into it and I want to talk
about that next okay we're going to move
on from Trump's very boring and sweaty
and low energy announcement that he's
running for president it really was sort
of like I'm running for president all
right okay well let's move on
um even Fox News cut away from the
speech and they didn't go back to it for
a while this is super interesting at a
certain point during the speech which
was expected to be under a half hour
Trump went an hour and ranted and raved
about executing drug dealers and so many
other different things when Trump
started talking about Angela Merkel
Fox News just straight up cut away his
friend Sean Hannity cutting away
remember I sent to
Angela remember Angela do you remember
Uncle nobody's remembering her now I'm
going to be just joining us president
Trump and Mar-A-Lago announcing his 2024
presidential run yeah so Hannity cutting
away that was at 9 40 p.m eastern time
at 9 44 p.m as you can see here they
still hadn't come back they were
interviewing Mike Huckabee
and that looks like Pete hegseth and
then at 9 46 p.m they also didn't come
back they were interviewing Jim Jordan
and
um oh I forgot the name of this woman
who was uh the great Alan Combs
sister-in-law I forget her name that was
at 9 46 p.m and then at 9 48 p.m they
were interviewing some guy I don't
recognize and Leo Terrell wearing a Leo
2.0 hat this is not a good sign for
Donald Trump and there was a story
floating around yesterday that the
Murdoch's and Fox News are totally off
the Trump train it was one of these
speculative but unconfirmed stories but
interestingly enough this morning early
this morning Maria Bartiromo by far one
of the biggest brown-nosers of Donald
Trump now for years who spread Trump's
conspiracy theories and everything even
Maria Bartiromo this morning potentially
after seeing the level of lack of energy
rather at yesterday's speech Maria
bartiroma hosted a panel all of whom
were criticizing Trump and saying a lot
of the stuff Trump is pulling were over
as Republicans take a look at this
that's that's the thing that people keep
pushing back on they don't want to go
into a whole nother storm of hate and
there is Trump derangement syndrome
right there's definitely and and I think
he started even that last night he
started with the China virus he started
with you know poking names at DeSantis
we've heard that and people are tired of
it look I also think wow that you know
DeSantis and young and like you said are
really the future of the party right
they're they're in a generation that I
think needs to come forward and as much
as you know his policies were good
Trump's office is in the first in the
first term I don't think the majority of
the country really wants to go back
there I'll say I live in Florida Florida
is fully behind the scientist no matter
what Trump wants to tell you they are
fully behind the scientist you know
what's interesting Ivanka Trump Ivanka
Trump yesterday says she's bowing out of
politics just after her father's
announcement uh the former first
daughter telling Fox and she'll be
staying out of the political Arena all
together yeah
so
um this really is fascinating because at
the end of the day you you almost start
wondering
how did Trump even end up running
because the polling has shifted
dramatically towards DeSantis who isn't
even running for anything at this point
not even all of Trump's family wants him
to do this Ivanka not even there she's
bowing out you know I love my father
butt sort of stuff
Maria Bartiromo seems to now be
regularly entertaining anti-trump guests
Fox News has started to do man on the
street interviews where they happen to
come across Republicans who want
DeSantis to be the nominee rather than
Donald Trump the New York Post also a
news corporation product puts out Trump
de Dumpty covers last week making fun of
Donald Trump you start to wonder who
around Trump actually wants him to do
this
and where you end up is it really does
seem like the guy has no friends other
than his own ego and this is all
directed by his own ego and it is going
to be I mean listen I'll say it it's
going to be an interesting two years it
also may be sort of a sad two years
it'll be good for the country of trump
uh uh crashes and burns
but it also may have some level of
sadness but let's not assume like we did
in 2015 and 2016 that Trump can't win
because it is very early it is very
early Anything Can Happen DeSantis
hasn't even announced anything and will
look at the polling a little bit later
in the show in the meantime
support the independent Progressive
media that you like if it's this show
make sure you're subscribed on YouTube
it's free make sure you're subscribed to
the podcast it's free if you want sign
up at joinpakman.com if you prefer Sam
cedar or The Young Turks or Brian Tyler
Cohen or whoever just make sure you're
supporting the infrastructure so that we
are well placed and well prepared not to
let let any of these extremists whether
it's DeSantis or Trump or whoever
actually win in 2024. we'll take a quick
break and then be right back
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com joinpakman.com
a geopolitical story of consequence that
developed over the last 24 hours which
is really just as much about reporting
as it is about foreign policy there was
were initial reports yesterday that
missiles had struck Poland and the
initial belief was this was Russia
probably accidentally in targeting
Ukraine
although it was not completely clear and
the belief now is that this was actually
an accident committed by Ukrainian
forces the latest reporting uh from CNN
as of this morning Poland's President
says missile that killed two likely
fired by Ukraine in defense against a
Russian attack
Polish president said the missile Polish
president Duda said the missile that
killed two people in eastern Poland
Tuesday was likely fired by Ukrainian
forces defending against a wave of
Russian missile strikes and that the
incident appeared to be an accident
quote there is no indication that this
was an intentional attack on Poland most
likely it was a russian-made s 300
rocket that was in a tweet he later told
a press conference there's a high chance
it was an air defense missile from the
Ukrainian side which fell on polish
territory in an accident while
intercepting incoming Russian missiles
Judas comments were in line with those
of two officials briefed on initial U.S
assessments who told CNN it appears the
missile originated in Ukraine although
it was Russian made
um this is important because listen
there's so many stories here number one
um
these military actions are serious
business and when we talk about
innocent bystanders
you're no more innocent if you're in
Poland where two were killed than you
are in Ukraine where the exact same
thing would happen either way when we're
talking about innocent bystanders we're
talking about innocent bystanders but
the unintended consequences
of
an invasion of Ukraine by Russia
are extraordinarily far-reaching in ways
that aren't even always considered uh um
at sort of as the primary question or
discussion the second thing that's
important to mention is the amount of
misinformation and disinformation and
conspiracy theories that floated around
in the roughly eight to ten hours after
the original reporting was this seems to
have been Russia Russia bombed Poland
okay we saw all of the following and
more
we saw Fox News personalities say Poland
should bomb Russia in response you can't
let Russia get away with this well it
turns out it wasn't Russia turns out it
actually now can you blame Russia
because Ukraine is defending itself from
Russian aggression well sure okay you
can have that conversation but these
Hawks on right-wing media
saying anything short of immediately
bombing Russia back is unacceptable it's
weak it's [ __ ] whatever the case may be
Russia didn't actually do this this was
an accident from Ukraine based on what
we know right now that's number one
number two conspiracy theories I'm not
even going to play it I was going to
play it and I said why even bother
conspiracy theory Charlie Kirk saying I
don't know I I hope this isn't a false
flag I hope this isn't a false flag I
have no evidence that it's a false flag
but I just hope it isn't and one of the
things that unfortunately happens in the
24-hour news cycle and again this is why
sometimes I can't do it because the
story is so big but in the 24-hour news
cycle particularly when there are
shootings and crimes I will often wait
an extra day to avoid fueling
disinformation or conspiracy theories
and sometimes you just have to wait a
little bit particularly when the news is
coming from half a world away
not that there isn't internet and
Reporting in those places but we don't
always figure out exactly what's going
on right away so this is now another
dimension to what's going on in the
Russian invasion of Ukraine this has
been going on now for months and months
we don't know how long it's going to go
we still don't know what Putin's end
game is we still don't know what the
ultimate resolution is there are now
divided there have always been that
there are increasingly divided opinions
about for how long and to what degree
should or should the United States not
be uh funding Ukraine's defense be it
through money or be it through weaponry
and equipment and we are now in a nine
month conflict it's shocking to say but
it was I believe it was February when we
first started reporting on this we're
now almost in December I have no idea
what the conclusion of this is going to
be but what we do know is the longer it
goes on just simply from a sort of like
entropy and statistical perspective the
more likely it is that more types of
innocent bystanders are going to be hurt
and are going to be killed good uh use
of restraint by the way by many in the
United States not Fox News not Charlie
Kirk but by many in the United States in
actually waiting until we have more
information about exactly what it is
that happened there and it now appears
that it was actually an errant Ukrainian
defense attempt that ended up killing
two people in Poland what should the
geopolitical consequences of that be I
don't know and we don't yet know what
the parties involved are thinking I want
to spend just one moment
um going through a few clips that are
all of MyPillow CEO and founder Mike
Lindell this isn't really about Mike
Lindell in particular but this is about
the sort of psychosis that seems to have
Afflicted so many on the right over the
last week as Republican failed to win
winnable seats in the House Senate and
governors races Republicans are going to
take control of the house they will not
have control of the Senate and they lost
some key gubernatorial races take a look
at this Mike pillow was at Mar-A-Lago
yesterday for Donald Trump's
announcement for 2024
he is now saying I have the proof carry
Lake really won the governor's race in
Arizona she didn't I have the proof that
Blake Masters really won the senate race
in Arizona he did not how long are they
going to do this how long are they going
to tell the exact same stories for which
they have no evidence it seems like it
is Years Years listen to this
are absolutely fought everything that
was done in Arizona
pot and who's gonna just the hip of the
spear for unraveling see there's n's and
ends of thousands of cities that are
looking for a place to reach out they're
going to do sworn affidavits of what
happened remember
affidavits are not evidence they can be
accepted as claims
that are still evaluated like testimony
affidavits are not evident strictly
speaking I don't think there's a judge
in this country that can't say we need a
new election down there in Arizona and
now can you imagine a new election in
Arizona there's going to be no new
election Steve bannon's already talking
about decertification or prevention of
certification again there's no such
thing carry Lake lost Blake Masters lost
more people voted for their opponents
that's what happened just for Kerry Lake
remember they took Mark fincham's to
they took Blake Masters they were all
stole and I don't care they were stoled
they were stoled folks it doesn't matter
what anyone says we already know this we
were watching it from the Edison report
we were watching it cyberly and cyberly
they were they stoled cyberly think of
it and we're watching just blatantly the
citizens were all watch so you have
imagined having three different camera
angles of a crime when you have a crime
of this magnitude committed you can't
certify this election yeah folks this is
part of why they lost in 2022. I I don't
want to say that the sole reason
Republicans did so terribly was their
insistence on Election denial but to
some degree
certain can that it's harping on it was
stoled as pillow says did not help them
this is now a religion it's not it's no
longer well we think 2020 was stolen no
now it's we think 22 was stolen we
believe they're going to steal 2024
unless we win in which case we zip our
lips and shut our mouths here's another
clip of pillow losing the little bits
that were that are left of his mind I
guess as the Cary Lake results came in
this sky is very unwell
what she has then was an image uh all
the images before they came in and did
The Trusted build so these uh these
teams uh these team of uh experts cyber
guy everything yeah first seven months
now have uh there was that came out with
the first report the second report this
is the one we've all been waiting for
because this shows actual machine
manipulation it shows it shows the
manipulation not just that they can be
manipulated but that our 2020 election
was deleted he has no such evidence and
he has never presented it it has been
two years now it's manipulated
um all these things and and not just
that but they also the election another
election they had in uh in Colorado so
you have two sets of proof there and
there is no proof excited Steve because
it's Vindicated it's here it's over the
uh these guys are guilty and and these
uh when these so you're if you when you
see these uh the credentials these guys
have by the way we put it up on praying
speech exclusively you can go there and
view this report and and the stuff that
backs it up where they got the stuff
from and uh so I looked for it there is
absolutely no proof there you know if
Mike pillow came forward and said you
know what
I was wrong
I don't have the proof I I don't have it
and even if I suspect that something was
was amiss
I don't have any of the proof I claim to
have I'm sorry I'm sorry for what I did
I would actually respect the guy to some
degree uh Mike uh pillow also yesterday
at Mar-A-Lago
with the completely and obviously
incorrect claim that today Ron DeSantis
would be endorsing Trump for president
we're halfway through the day more and
DeSantis has not done that here we are
live with Mar-A-Lago
they just had a ball with them
almost all of them they asked me about
Ron DeSantis running against Donald
Trump and I said after tonight Ronald
just endorse him in the morning you
gotta believe that why would you want to
waste all that time energy money and
everything else so very exciting here
and another one of Mike pillow's
predictions that obviously isn't coming
true unless in the next few hours Ron
DeSantis decides to come out and endorse
Trump for president I don't believe
that's going to happen and if you if you
allow me to bet on that I'm not a
betting man but I would bet on that we
are going to take a quick break make
sure that you are following us on
Instagram at davidpackman show all of
these clips we played are on our
Instagram after this short break we're
going to look at polling we're going to
look at the existing campaign for being
Trump's vice president there's really
one person right now who's uh in the
middle of that campaign and that's
Marjorie Taylor green and so many other
things
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show all right
I'm not going to do this to you even
every week never mind every day for the
next two years but because last night
failed former president Donald Trump
announced another run for president in
2024 we have to look at what the polling
says right now not only about Trump
versus other Republicans but also
general election polling I was telling
you earlier we have a very different
situation now for Trump's run than we
did in 2016 or 2020. now Donald Trump
number one has become a clear loser 2018
wasn't great for Republicans 2020 was a
disaster for Trump and Republicans and
2022 was the red wave that I guess could
have been but wasn't for republicans and
so now you have a republican electorate
not completely sick of and tired of
trump but certainly much more so than in
years past and you have a guy that is
very well liked among Republicans and
that is Ron DeSantis the governor of
Florida who was just re-elected by a 19
nearly 20 point margin that is a blowout
win for Ron DeSantis we don't yet know
the impact of last night's announcement
it that Donald Trump is running on the
polling but we do have a bunch of polls
released after the November 8th midterms
and they're very bad for Donald Trump
let's take a look at this you can find
this on the 538
Republican primary 2024 page and what we
see is that there is a seven letter
Insight poll released today that shows
Ron DeSantis plus eight over Donald
Trump still with a lot of undecideds we
do have a single morning consult poll
from yesterday that still shows Trump
ahead by 14 over DeSantis but then we
have a CWS research poll looking at
Texas which has DeSantis plus 11 over
Donald Trump in Georgia Florida New
Hampshire and Iowa
WPA intelligence polls which are okay
they're rated A B C by 538 all have Ron
DeSantis ahead between plus 11 and plus
26. we have a legere poll of the
national Republican primary which has
the santis at plus two and then we have
a yougov poll which is the best ranked
pollster of all of these at a B plus
with Ron DeSantis plus seven Rhonda
santis Plus 7. this is a very different
situation than in years past we will
maybe know by Monday maybe next Tuesday
or Wednesday what the polling looks like
after Trump's announcement will Trump's
announcement help him in that it will
invigorate people to say okay DeSantis
isn't even running Trump's running I'm
throwing my support behind Trump or will
Trump's early announcement which was
ill-advised according to many right-wing
strategists actually hurt Trump that
would be an interesting thing to see now
also notable and again I'm not going to
do this to you every day or even every
week for the next two years if we look
at general election polls for 2024 and
it is so early but it is still
interesting if you look at a new poll
released by legere again A B C pollster
in a hypothetical Biden versus Trump
matchup it is Biden plus three and in a
hypothetical Biden versus DeSantis
matchup it is DeSantis plus two in that
poll DeSantis polling way better and
then in a bunch of different Biden polls
for 2024 from morning consult it is
Biden winning in every single one it's
Biden defeating Christie Chaney Pompeo
Rick Scott Hogan gnome Tim Scott Tom
Cotton Holly Cruz Haley Romney Rubio
Pence the best outcome is DeSantis
DeSantis is the only one that in that
poll is even even
with Joe Biden and then this one from
right before the election uh actually
this is from New York New York's a very
blue State kind of meaningless okay so
the other point here is
Trump and other Republicans short of Ron
DeSantis aren't even polling well in
hypothetical matchups against Joe Biden
Joe Biden also hasn't announced that
he's running in 2024. so a very
different situation here
we are taking a picture right now
and then we're going to give it six or
so months and see how things are looking
in the spring but it is not at all clear
even though many Republicans insist this
nomination is Trump's for the taking it
is not clear that it is really Trump's
for the taking and it is not at all
clear that if Trump wins that nomination
that he is in a strong position to
actually win in 2024. at which point by
the way he will be you know nearly 80
years old and that's a whole other story
which we will get to the point is this
could all end in genuine historic
humiliation for Donald Trump there is a
campaign to be Donald Trump's vice
president going on right now
and there is really one person who is in
that campaign and it is radical
repugnant Republican congresswoman
Marjorie Taylor green Marjorie Taylor
green is openly running to be Trump's VP
she is trying to dissuade people like
Ron DeSantis and when it looked like
maybe Carrie Lake would be the next
governor of Arizona Kerry Lake from
running
partially because she wants to be
Trump's VP she believes her best shot at
being the vice presidential pick is if
Donald Trump is the nominee and we're
going to get that in a moment Marjorie
Taylor green yesterday was confronted
with a very good question a very obvious
question if Trump is so strong if Trump
is so powerful if Trump is so revered in
the Republican party why did so many of
the people that Donald Trump endorsed
lose and Marjorie Taylor green just sort
of like with a throw everything at the
wall and see if any of it makes sense
answer listen to how she answered the
question Trump endorsed candidates
I would say there's I would say it
depends on the district I think there's
a lot of varying factors
redistricting happened and that was
based on the the census that was pretty
much pre-covered a lot of people moved
out of those districts over the past two
years okay so let's so
oh my goodness so first of all
redistricting only matters in
Congressional races
Trump's biggest losses in the contested
races of consequence that would have
made a difference
Kerry Lake in Arizona that's the entire
State redistricting doesn't matter Blake
Masters in Arizona Senate races are the
entire State redistricting doesn't
matter
um Doug mastriano and Mehmet Oz in
Pennsylvania Tudor Dixon in Michigan
these are all Statewide races
redistricting doesn't matter then
Marjorie Taylor green pulls well a lot
of people move during the pandemic to
other states unless you can make the
case that it was disproportionately
Republicans that moved that also isn't
really a good explanation for why
Trump's endorsements ended up falling
flat none of these explanations make
sense but remember
Marjorie Taylor green is desperate to be
Trump's VP so she has to come up with
something other than you know a lot of
people kind of don't like Trump I think
that plays the part
um I think I think Canada by Canada
sometimes one campaign has run really
well and sometimes one is not but I
would also say the media plays a big
part ah so then we get to really just
blame the media the media leans pretty
hard left and so when Republican
candidates when we run for office not
only are we running against a Democrat
opponent we're also running against the
media a good bit of the time and that's
really not fair so I think there's a lot
of factors at play and president Trump's
win record uh is is historic most of his
candidates won very few of his
candidates lost yeah and again remember
even Republicans are admitting to the
absurdity of that statement Trump's
record which he says oh we were like 215
or something
every day it's a different number that
he claims you mostly endorse incumbents
who usually win
or Republicans in safe red races
that is not impressive if I was in the
endorsement game
I could have a really good endorsement
record because there are quite literally
hundreds of races in which it's obvious
who's going to win would it really be
meaningful would it really be meaningful
if I actually called it in that way
because I hate to say it a couple
chimpanzees could probably call most of
the races where it mattered where it was
contested where it could have made a
difference in the balance Trump failed
miserably someone who also failed
miserably in their endorsements is Tulsi
gabbard and after the break we're going
to talk a little bit about that
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
let's talk briefly about former Democrat
and former Democratic presidential
candidate and former democratic
congresswoman Tulsi gabbard the other
day on Twitter I asked the question what
is tool c's next pivot now that almost
everyone or is it everyone she endorsed
lost or may lose we found out what the
next pivot is going to be and I'm going
to tell you in a moment but before we do
that if you want to find someone with an
even worse endorsement record than Trump
you have to look at tool C look at this
the new Republic with a nice write-up
about this nearly every Republican Tulsi
gabbard endorse lost the election these
are the numbers Tulsi gabbard endorsed
13 Republican candidates and 10 of them
lost and she endorsed some real
extremists for someone who has made the
claim that it is the Democratic party
that lost her
that she is leaving the Democratic party
because she is the moderate she is the
critical thinker she is the for lack of
a better term enlightened Centrist and
then all of a sudden she's endorsing
Herschel Walker she's endorsing Carrie
Lake John Gibbs that's not critical
thinking and it's certainly not
moderation those are some of the most
extreme candidates out there the new
Republic summarized this she in the
house endorsed John Gibbs who I
interviewed he's out of his mind uh and
he lost Tom Barrett and Joe Kent all of
them lost
on the Senate side she endorsed Blake
Masters who thankfully lost one of the
worst and most dangerous candidates this
cycle Adam laxalt in Nevada thankfully
he lost and done balduck in New
Hampshire good thing he lost as well and
then as far as Governors go Tulsi
endorsed Kerry Lake we learned yesterday
that yes indeed she lost Darren Bailey
in Illinois lost Tudor Dixon in Michigan
she lost and lizelden in New York the
three people she endorsed to one were JD
Vance for Ohio Senator he was already
well ahead at the point at which she
endorsed him Mike Lee for Utah senator
okay that's maybe the most contested one
here even though he was doing very well
in the polls and then Christie known for
South Dakota governor she's very popular
in South Dakota meaningless endorsement
she was obviously going to win so a
disastrous endorsement record for Tulsi
so then we get to what is her next step
what's her next pivot some of you wrote
to me and said tulsi's next pivot is
going to be becoming
overtly transphobic because that's
what's doing really well right now among
the Republican Party well maybe but the
actual news is that Tulsi gabbard has
joined Fox News we used to joke about
this months and months and months ago
when a year maybe longer when we started
to see the tool C transformation
we all were joking she is really lined
up to be a Fox News contributor and it
was
a joke but one of those jokes where you
say Well it actually could become a
reality she is now a Fox News
contributor the hill reporting Tulsi
gabbard inc's contributor deal with Fox
News
a spokesperson for Fox confirmed
gabbard's hiring on Tuesday
she has emerged as a leading critic of
liberals
and it has been campaigning with a
number of trump-backed Republicans
during the recent cycle she regularly
has appeared on Fox over several months
she is guest hosted Tucker Carlson
tonight she was on a fox's afternoon
table talk program the five and occupied
the seat typically reserved for
Democrats and liberals so is this the
end of I mean listen we're dealing with
a right winger now Tulsi gabbard is the
absolutely typical reactionary
populist-esque
I don't even know if the word
libertarian applies she was very clearly
a Democrat because being a Democrat was
how she was going to be elected to the
house representing her home state of
Hawaii
and there was really nothing special
about being a Democrat some of the
people who fond over her from the left
were saying well she's against regime
change Wars who isn't who isn't and oh I
Hillary was going to get us into three
Wars was she Biden's gonna get us into
three Wars well he hasn't so far and
he's halfway through his first term
once that fell out of favor or was no
longer useful she started the pivot well
we need to defend speech and there's a
little too much wokeness and suppression
of speech on the left and I can see it
clearly because I'm inside it was all Bs
and she has now gone full circle she
endorsed the most extremist lunatics
running in 2022 just about every single
one of them lost thankfully and now
she's a Fox News contributor what does
she have to look forward to well maybe
this check this out I am going to play
For You video of Fox News propagandist
Sean Hannity's sulking recognition
that extremist Republican secessionist
election denier Kerry Lake lost
I really took pleasure in Kerry Lake
losing you know when it came to someone
like Don balduck losing in New Hampshire
to Maggie Hassan I was glad because
balduck is a disaster and Hassan is fine
and the better choice was Hassan but I
didn't take a deep visceral pleasure in
it
I take a deep visceral pleasure and
carry Lake's loss because she is so
extreme and she was so arrogant in her
being extreme and she was so confident
she was going to win and Trump was so
confident she was going to win and it
really would have been a disaster I also
have friends in Arizona who were really
hoping she would lose so I'm glad all
around
here is Sean Hannity while wrapping up
an interview with Adam Carolla
offhandedly mentioning I don't know I
guess they kind of called it for Katie
Hobbs who by the way shouldn't even have
been running and I'll address that in a
moment too check this out land safely
and be alive you know what I think that
says it all uh Adam Carolla as always we
appreciate you being with us thank you
sir
all right apparently they did have a
drop in Arizona and fox is projecting
that Democratic Secretary of State who
should have recused herself Katie Hobbs
been elected governor of Arizona
Straight Ahead yeah apparently I don't
know they're telling me something like
the decision desk called the raise I
don't know there was a dump there was a
vote dump she shouldn't even have been
running so this is this is great I
absolutely love this and on the entire
she shouldn't even have been running
thing listen
if you want to seriously talk about when
a secretary of state runs for governor
should there be some kind of special
um circumstance where they have to go
through a certain distancing from how
the election is run because it's
absolutely true
secretaries of state to different
degrees in different states are involved
in the running of the election and if
they are candidates in the very election
they are helping to run you can argue
that's a conflict I am more than willing
to explore that and figure out what sort
of general rules should there be when a
secretary of state is a candidate but
Brian Kemp was Secretary of State in
Georgia when he ran for governor against
Stacey Abrams and none of these
Republicans said a word about it and
when Kemp actually worked to close down
early voting reduce polling places all
of that stuff Kemp was actually doing it
and then Stacey Abrams said hey you know
some of this stuff is like a little bit
sketchy because this guy's a candidate
and he's also making these decisions
all of a sudden these very same
Republicans they didn't say well Kemp
shouldn't even be running because he's
Secretary of State they came out and
said Oh Stacy Abrams is an election
denier Stacy Abrams is an election
denier so they are complete and total
Hypocrites complete and total Hypocrites
they are pathetic and I just love I mean
look at look at this face from Hannity
look at this sulking face uh I don't
know they're kind of telling me
something about a vote dumb but I don't
know they say she won but she shouldn't
even have been a candidate okay uh great
stuff good thing Carrie Lake lost we
have a voicemail number and that number
is
2192 David P here's a you know speaking
of Awakenings Tulsi gabbard had an
Awakening and went from the left to the
right Dave Rubin had an Awakening and
went to the left from the left to the
right uh here's a really good voicemail
about the way these Awakenings differ
when it's left to right versus right to
left take a listen
hey David it's Tommy have you ever
noticed that when people shift political
sides that if they go from the left to
the right usually off the deep end you
know like Jesse dollar used to be you
know hardcore conservatives like some
terrible things now on the left and he
makes a lot of sense and he's
intelligent and well informed but then
you get people like Tulsi
or diamond and silk who used to be
Democrats and now they're on the
Republican side and they're just out of
their minds what's the deal with that
this is a very interesting observation
very very interesting observation I
think there's a couple reasons why going
from left to right leads to extremist
lunacy and going from right to left is
less commonly leading to that kind of
lunacy by definition I mean when we talk
about what is the right wing the right
wing generally speaking is reactionary
and it is fear oriented if your only
issue for why you go left to right is
you know I realized instead of a 37 top
tax rate we should really have like a 22
flat tax okay
that is not
radical in the sense that many of these
other beliefs are radical and I'm not
aware of anybody who went from left to
right because of a disagreement about
what the top tax rate should be
generally speaking the reasons people go
left to right are based in fear and they
are extraordinarily reactionary it's
stuff about you know they've been
brainwashed about transgender or they've
become convinced that anyone who gets an
abortion is literally a murderer or that
Democrats want to open the floodgates
with Mexican rapists who will rape your
daughters and sell drugs and whatever
right
Theory the the what pulls people to the
right are
ignorant and factually incorrect but
also reactionary fear-based ideologies
and so the people susceptible to such a
drastic 180 because let's be honest
if you're 16 and your political views
change significantly you're just
learning about what the world is like
it's more believable when a 40 year old
man like Dave Rubin or a 40 year old
woman like Tulsi gabbard do a 180. you
have to wonder is it a grift and this is
just they're choosing the most
profitable character to play
or are they so ignorant or susceptible
to cult mentalities that they are
willing to be sucked in by definition
that is going to lead to people being
extreme on the other hand and I agree
people like Jesse dalamore Jank ugur
others who used to be on the right and
and go to the left they come to the left
for very non-radical beliefs hey you
know what I've realized we have the
money to provide everybody a basic level
of a standard of living
with the taxes that we are collecting
I want to be part of the movement that
wants to do that it's not fear-based
it's not reactionary it's actually
empathetic and so at its core
I believe that that is the the most
important reason why we see left to
right Awakenings be extraordinarily
extreme and right to left Awakenings
um not be that let me know your thoughts
we have a great bonus show for you today
Raphael Warnock is suing Georgia over
early voting restrictions for the
December 6th runoff U.S the U.S has
fined Airlines U.S government has fined
Airlines seven and a half million
dollars for canceled flights we'll talk
about when this happened and why it's
controversial and relevant and Mitch
McConnell is facing a leadership
challenge from Rick Scott in the Senate
where will this one go we will talk
about it on the bonus show you can sign
up and get instant access at
joinpakman.com